Android patterns for performance
It's important for your app to stay up-to-date
To provide the latest social summaries, news and weather reports for your users.
But in fact repeated synchronization
May be the worst thing for the performance of your application.
My name is Colt McCannless. I say there is a fixed base
To synchronize data on the network,
It is not a lot of synchronization.
This is a very widespread situation.
Your app is active on the user
Or maybe it's the last application you used.
You want to make sure that you have plenty of new data available
So they do not close your app or turn their attention elsewhere.
So synchronize, synchronize frequently, scan connection with server,
Request new data and download it as much as you can.
But in fact, this is a bad idea.
First, it destroys the user's battery.
As we have said before,
Communication with the network is the largest depleted battery.
It does not exhaust the battery to initialize the slide only
But keep it active for an additional period ranging from 20 to 60 seconds
After you finish your order, this battery drains as well.
In fact, things may end badly
Each network request activates the wireless connection
And you have to pay for it.
This is bad. Second, think about the sheer volume of the bit
Which your app is responsible for
On the user's phone.
For users with limited data bundles,
This may be a disaster.
I mean one application exhausts the entire monthly data transfer rate
Just because it continues to query the server for new data?
Not a good idea.
This also has a negative effect because the slower the connection
The duration of the wireless connection has been extended to help with data transfer.
Which means that you can not afford to take a call only during a call
But you also lose more battery power as a result.
So the excess syncing of the limit is bad.
But let's be realistic.
Your app needs data to provide the user with the best experience.
We can not stop syncing completely, do we?
You do not really have to.
There are some easy tips you can follow
It will give the user the same sense of effectiveness while reducing the number of requests required.
The key to this solution is to understand the difference between things that should happen now
And things that can be postponed.
For example, if the user takes action
Asking him to update his news story right now,
You should start this order now.
But in the second and third types
You can really start improving performance.
I mean those requests that occur at regular intervals
Which are updated but not now directly.
If not very important now,
You can then follow a smarter way of how to synchronize it.
For example, you should not regularly ask the server for updates.
All you do is waste your data transfer rate and battery
The server tells you there is no change.
It is better for you instead to exploit other services,
Such as Google Cloud Messaging
Which makes the server send a signal to the application when new content is present.
This will reduce the battery power the phone consumes
It will also reduce the total number of server responses that you should pay attention to.
If you happen to have a synchronization done,
Be sure not to do so at regular intervals.
Remember that this is wasting resources.
And that there will be no new content waiting for you most of the time.
Instead, use a Undo style based on responses.
For example, if new data is not available,
Double the time it waits before it is realized again.
If nothing is available the next time,
Double the waiting time again.
However, you can still sync data
But will slowly move away from higher activity
Depending on the number of times the information was updated by the server.
Also remember that you can also adjust the frequency
Based on user activity.
If you can, for example, find out if a user is driving a car
Or if the phone is in sleep mode,
You can guess it will not need the data
At the same rate.
On the other side,
If you notice that the phone was silent for eight hours
Activity suddenly began,
There is a high probability that the user has been awakened
And that this is the time to start the synchronization request.
Finally, feel free to adjust the sync frequency
On the device status.
Waiting for a connection or connecting to a Wi-Fi network to sync
Helps keep the battery
While users are moving out of the house.
The good news is that you can update your app to use these styles
Without having to write a huge amount of code.
GCMNetworkManager is an API of Google Play services
Which helps to schedule network tasks
And manage the transmission in batches for you.
This greatly facilitates the implementation of common patterns,
Such as waiting to connect to the network and attempts to reconnect to the network
And steady decline.
Basically, all the wonderful things you need
In one useful API interface.
If you are wondering how to use your application for the network,
Be sure to check out the Network Traffic Tool
Within Android Studio.
You'll easily see the frequency of data transfer
And the amount of data transmitted during each connection.
This is of course the most important thing, is not it?
Watch some videos, good your app,
Make your users more satisfied.
But it is not over yet.
Check out the rest of the Android Performance Patterns content.
And do not forget to join the Google+ community as well.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.